well las vegas is a city that is
constantly evolving constantly changing
while the hospitality industry is still
our driving economic force it too has
changed the look the service but not
always the people heather mills
introduces us to three women who have
lived the westgate story
what's now the westgate hotel was once
the world's largest and still one of the
city's oldest and believe it or not some
who've been here decades and can share
its grand account
if las vegas has an unspoken motto it's
out with the old and in with the new
the bygone era is just that history but
if walls could talk these walls would
have one heck of a story and as it turns
out so do these cocktail waitresses when
i went down george burns he was so funny
he made me laugh so hard with his
cigar and his um
he had a working girl with him
and he said come up to my room and get
all my flowers betty gadini's been
serving customers here for more than
four decades
she remembers the early days kenny
rogers
when i first started in 79 kitty rogers
was in the lounge he was a superstar and
he used uh somebody else's credit card
so i didn't know his name it was a place
to see and be seen the best gold the
best jewelry and the best high heels the
best dress change over the years and not
just the casino's name who wants that
tuxedos even the drinks are different
before it was just basic bourbon coke
bourbon seven you know whiskey step
whatever joanie dixon has been
cocktailing here for almost 40 years i
started as a bus girl and they
promoted me as a food server i did that
for a year and then when i turned 22 i
became a cocktail waitress and over the
years she's seen it all sylvester
stallone and he was kind of short he
wasn't tall
you know i've seen muhammad ali i've
seen almost all the fighters the west
gate was home to all the big boxing
matches and its showrooms packed with
resident superstars like liberace
flamboyan very very very
awesome
beautiful
personality a lot of warmth and meyer
has also been around since its heyday
and she says so of a lot of her
customers we have a lot of people come
back over here and they're looking for
us they're looking for a few familiar
faces and it's those faces we like the
family here that keep these ladies
smiling this is where i grew up
basically grown up but not ready to hang
it up i have to stay active i don't
think i'll retire i'm just going to keep
working until i can't do it anymore i
mean one day maybe i will open but not
for now not anytime soon heather mills
live local now